ukrainians have suffered immensely in
this war but it appears that the
conflict is not going well for russia's
forces by some estimates they've already
lost as many troops in 28 days as they
did in 10 years of war in afghanistan
holly williams is about 100 miles west
of the capital kiev holly good morning
good morning we were here when russia
launched its first missiles and
airstrikes a month ago today but instead
of a lightning invasion russian forces
appear to have stalled with ukraine
claiming it's killed six russian
generals and even destroyed a russian
navy ship this morning the human cost of
this war though is horrifying
if vladimir putin thought he'd score an
easy victory in ukraine he knows better
now
in just one month between seven and
fifteen thousand russian soldiers have
been killed according to a nato official
the ukrainians are still out gunned yet
in some places they're clawing back
territory from the invaders but the cost
of this brutal invasion is being paid in
the lives of civilians the besieged city
of mariopol has been laid to waste by
putin's forces with more than a hundred
thousand people still thought to be
trapped inside
fifteen-year-old masha made it out of
mario pole but had her right leg
amputated after it was torn apart in a
russian strike
her doctor says she's so traumatized she
couldn't eat for days it breaks my heart
hearts of all ukrainians and every free
person on the planet in a video message
last night ukraine's president vladimir
zelensky accused russia of trying to
wipe ukrainians off the face of the
earth
this is only the beginning for russia on
the ukrainian land
in the city of jittermeir sergei is
sifting through the wreckage of his home
he spent 12 years building it for his
family he told us but russian airstrikes
destroyed it earlier this month killing
four in his neighborhood one of them was
sergei's daughter katja who's left
behind a one-year-old daughter
i wish i'd died in her place
the pain doesn't go away
who do you blame
for this
of course i blame putin he said if i had
him in my hands i'd butcher him like a
goat
sir hey says he'll raise his
granddaughter and like other ukrainians
he's determined to rebuild
in the shattered city of harkiv this
week a cellist played in the rubble
creating beauty even amid the terror of
this ugly war
this is a country where the will to
survive and fight for freedom at any
cost is simply staggering
[Music]
in that video message president
zielenski called on people all over the
world to protest against russia's
invasion and he said that ukraine has
not received the aircraft and modern air
defense systems that it wants from its
allies
vlad holly my heart simply breaks for
sir hey and his family and all
ukrainians who are suffering through
this thank you for your reporting we
appreciate it